Maria dobra Jing Maria hello
I'm very happy you're here because it
could have been very different as far as
I know you could have faced five years
in prison
initially it was 15 yes
then he cut it down to five and first
idea was that I would be given the time
I spent on remand and then returned home
however he didn't go as I expected I was
given a longer sentence let's start from
the very beginning what were you doing
in the u.s. why were you there
oh she was yeah so supposed to feel
awful I was studying I am rolling the
master's degree at the University in
Washington to study international
relations after I obtain a work permit
and I was invited to work at University
as an assistant professor and then two
days later I was arrested yeah you gotta
started frankly speaking I know you were
not just studying right you're a
political activist yes that's true but
these two things do not contradict each
other I can tell you that when you come
to study international relations it's
only natural to do something practical
in this area too I always had a lot of
respect for us and I still have and I
also love my home country dearly so I
thought it was only reasonable to do
something for the sake of friendship
between the two countries to try to
improve relations and engage in civil
diplomacy is that still the case I still
want to do that very good and bad people
is the same everywhere I believe that
your American people should really start
paying attention to what is happening in
their country but there are good people
there I know this the way things that
good relations between Russia and us
will eventually be built on the
foundation of friendship that's exactly
what I was basically doing building
bridges between the countries to shared
interest in gun rights and I thought
that everything would be okay
unfortunately the US authorities had
been busy disrupting such activities
probably didn't want peace was possible
after all what happens do you think it's
possible for relation
between Russia and the US to improve of
course I think that what happens to meet
and how Russia is generally depicted in
the US has really nothing to do with
Russia per se they just picked a
scapegoat and especially now with all
those petty games the Republicans and
Democrats are playing for power the
establishment has nothing to do with
people's war with democracy the
politicians are just fighting for power
and that's why they need a foreign
threat an enemy who could make an ideal
enemy so they picked Russia you know
Russia is blamed for everything even
though there are no grounds for any of
the accusations and then these dot let's
take some student like myself and put
her behind bars and say she's
responsible for everything
it was just absurd if I were a US
national I would be offended to hear
something like that my own government
treats me like that they think I really
don't understand anything that I cannot
choose a can of my own and I need
Russian interference to family make a
choice it's just ridiculous and why
should I this may sound naive and
Nepalese are Slovenia yes the thing is
would have happen if the political
climate had been more settled of the
Trump became president I think of the
Bosnian branagh trumpet this is la
política Canyon Taurus it certainly
political climate is one thing and the
other thing is racism I regret to say it
but there is racism in us and is getting
stronger
look if I belong to any other ethnic
group not brushing there would be no
case today however if you are Russian
and you are in gs there's reason to be
worried and I'm living proof let's talk
about your arrest how did it happen
and what did they charge you with at
first that was a terrible day it's hard
for me to recall what happened my friend
and I we were about to move after I got
a job all our things were already tapped
up and then I heard this loud banging on
the door so my friend went to see what
he was and then come back I became
nervous and then I heard someone say my
name Maria come in
I slowly came up to the door it was
around the corner I open it to see some
12 FBI agents in full gear but assault
rifles they told me to step out from the
apartment in handcuff me asking whether
I had anything I can use to hurt them
what a copybook maybe that's how I was
arrested and until yesterday I was
behind bars today was my first sunrise
in the free world oh I mean Ida stylist
exporting individual swab out the door
what's the Ornish know straight across a
what did they accuse you of initially
espionage I was never charged with
espionage that was simply speculation
the media blew it all out of proportion
in their stories perhaps because of how
I looked and some fantasy they made us
maybe they've seen too many Hollywood
movies and thought this is how a spy
should look I don't know maybe they were
just two things am i right saying that
you testified before Congress behind
closed doors and those hearings lasted
for some eight or nine hours congressmen
were asking you questions and telling
you to provide thousands of papers what
was that all about the choice all that
the labeling and investigation started
the Senate Intelligence Committee sent
me a request asking whether I would like
to talk about my activities in relation
to the National Rifle Association the
National Prayer Breakfast and why I
visited as well as my ties with
Alexander torsion and I said ok no
problem the next day I called up mr.
torsion and yeah because when you also
DJ stomp our feet risk us awesome was
not before your arrest
yes so I told him about that letter and
asked him what he thought I should do I
just wanted to hear his personal advice
because I do respect him and he's an old
friend of mine a very good friend and a
mentor tooth that's why I asked him and
he said Maria give them all the
documents we are not doing anything
wrong we only want peace and friendship
to prevail and that's the truth I don't
know why they decided to search my place
I had given all the documents to the
Senate two weeks prior to that I gave it
all voluntarily to show that I'd done
nothing wrong I had nothing to hide
what were they asking you eight hours is
a long time he asked me about everything
I had been doing us how I enrolled in
that program and what was the purpose of
the visit of the NRA representatives to
Russia actually after my home was
searched I didn't change any passwords
in my computer didn't delete any files
that's because again I had done nothing
wrong I hand it over all the documents
voluntarily so I really don't know why
they needed to arrest me if it was just
because I didn't register then they
could have just simply fined me for that
and that's it
why such cruelty for what money do I
mean it got scoped prettiest epistle
right after your arrest the US media
said that a note was found after the
police searched and supposedly you wrote
that note it read discs or how to
respond to an FSB offer of employment
what was that I didn't write that note I
see it was my friend who wrote that down
that's first second I can only guess
what he meant by that as far as I can
tell by the conversations we had listen
if my work eventually transformed into
something more serious and maybe could
have attracted some interest but history
is never happy tatical is it knows no
ifs duration security services were not
interested in my theories in u.s. period
how can a note like that be considered
proof especially if it wasn't even mine
I really don't understand how it could
have become evidence in my case my yo-yo
and when you myself in it I mean was
that peace Kimble out what the kind of
the note was not the only thing that
happened to you your story unravel
during the premiere of a movie about
Russian female spy starring Jennifer
Lawrence regrettably spies were ready to
use sex for promotions new contacts and
a chance to reach high-profile US
officials there was a Christian or when
it got ah this was the image the
mainstream media exploited along with
the Attorney General's Office which had
to apologize later right what was your
response to these allegations we argued
over like you know at the studio they
should be embarrassed us positions
top of the country that protects women's
rights they should be ashamed of their
behavior you just made the allegations
based on my looks I have a great family
I'm proud of it both of my grandmother's
or teachers who shared the same name I
have nothing to do with these sex
stories but about my life how do I live
on yes they apologized but what about me
now I was extremely surprised and
saddened that the judge did not do
anything about it
the only statement by the judge was it
took me five minutes to realize that the
communications you have submitted proof
are messages between friends back in
Russia I had nothing to do with us
it was completely absurd I thought she
should defend me defend my honor and my
dignity because she was also a woman
they could have accused me of being
anybody the foreign agent or whatever
but those allegations as if they didn't
know they were lying
he knew it they saw the messages they
realized it was a deliberate lie to
commit detain without any chance of bail
what do I do now with my reputation
bottom line it was a disgrace for us
what that is do you agree it was done on
purpose to create an image for the US
audience the public is familiar with
America's corporate area yes absolutely
absolutely they just took some Hollywood
cliches and made me the scapegoat the
color of my hair and my features served
as proof of guilt that's the way it
should be because we see this in the
movies it was clickbait and made for
good headlines on TV if you remove the
sex from money hype the case itself is
pretty boring was I for an agent or not
that's all bureaucratic not really
exciting the added flames to the story I
start with my own eyes that there is no
justice in u.s. more than 90 percent of
defendants plead guilty to a wait jury
because they know they'll be convicted
what kind of justice are we talking
about little car teacher escapes one of
the most celebrated newspapers in the US
the New York Times said that you were a
person who was supposed to organize a
meeting between Trump and Putin what
would you say to that
Malcolm young do you think too much of
me absolutely not the only thing I did
visibie is Trump was asked him a
question at a conference and he
initially wasn't even meant to be there
it was an animal libertarians conference
in Las Vegas Nevada and I was interested
in the event as a person who shares
these views Trump made a surprise visit
and I had a chance to ask a question and
lo and behold I asked him a question
about Russia simply because I am
Russians I don't know why everyone was
so surprised there is nothing strange
about that I'm often asked why did you
ask him about sanctions I did it because
trade is the foundation for good
relations between countries that's been
true for thousands of years trade has
always been a solid foundation to
improve ties so it was natural that I
asked him about the sanctions first and
foremost it affects the people of both
countries any privateer ships alone are
all the total standing but it normally
do did you ever consider using legal
means to force top US TV channels to
change their narrative and are you
considering it now will you have other
matters to do why don't we see just
anyone with any day at all I'm looking
at possible options my return to Russia
is not the end of the story it is just a
beginning for me it's not right to just
get over it and think it's all in the
past it's not famous want in this life I
must now become a voice for those who
are unduly accused and more treated I
feel I have to do some human rights
campaigning as for my personal case I
need to discuss it with my family first
I think there would be a decision very
soon my treaty but besides you signed a
plea deal we were watching the case very
closely just like all Russia some
lawyers said the prosecutors might not
have enough evidence to prove your guilt
why then take a plea bargain imagine you
are in a foreign country away from your
parents you have no contact with your
family you're locked up in solitary
confinement it's very cold and you sit
on the floor you might be facing a 15
year sentence I thought
about how old I was going to be and
whether my parents were gonna be alive
when that date came and then you find
out that according to statistics and you
asked about 98% of defendants who face a
jury get convicted so the chance of you
losing is while quite high besides who
would have been judging me I would have
faced during Washington the people who
watch CNN the people who already been
fed this narrative and with those people
you wouldn't have mattered what I was
being accused of I would have been on
trial for being Russian I'd have been
sentenced to 15 years so I believe I
made the only right decision there was
no other ways they were strong women any
Swahili who said you put in solitary
confinement why is that standard
procedure done a practicum yeah anybody
might know it's not standard procedure I
don't know why they had to be so cruel I
tend to think this is just conjecture
then maybe they were trying to break my
will or something like that learn some
secrets but I didn't have any secrets I
think that when we started those
briefings as they call them with the
prosecutors they understood everything
after the first or second talks it had
all my computers which they still do and
all of my papers I hadn't delete
anything in the search through
everything there is nothing there but
they couldn't admit there was nothing
they had to justify why do as taxpayers
paid for the show what said he did it a
fool what I knew I was no violet
definitely this was a way to apply
pressure yes of course no doubt about it
do we see chaps would you be willing to
go back to the US now or ever what you
live up chicag w-well first of all I
can't go to the rest now I'm not allowed
to let you do my most rational of still
play in light of my hideous crime trying
to build bridges between the two
countries I'm being sarcastic here of
course I'm not allowed to set foot in
the US for 10 years it's forbidden and
you know I wouldn't have been refrained
from going there at this point because
right now the attitude towards Russians
is not great I'm living proof of that
such as New Rochelle Gotham put it in
here
you shouldn't tell us about how you met
mr. Toshi oh he was he the one who sent
you to America
what role did he play in no no one sent
me to do us I always respected mr.
tortion as a more experienced friend and
a mentor we met as a demonstration in
support of gun rights he has always been
in favor of the right to carry guns and
I respect him for that it wasn't always
been a regular stand it's never popular
really but he has consistently advocated
for gun rights regardless he has never
sent me anywhere of course he had
travelled to do West long before he did
and he needed no help from me so our
relationship was that of a mentor
student basis and have a great deal of
respect for him I don't know what has
been happening to him recently since we
haven't been in touch
I hope he's well and I hope we'll have a
chance to talk your activism regarding
the Second Amendment and that we need to
have something like that in Russia
how did that all come about wanna call
data no no it came from my family my dad
taught me how to handle a gun and this
interest of mine grew into an NGO to
protect the rights of people who found
themselves in situations that required
self-defense it's important to me and my
views on the issue haven't changed I'll
tell you what the curious thing is on
the second day after my rest Russian
diplomats came to me even though gun
rights have never been on the official
Russian government agenda and even
though I have never been a pro Kremlin
activist the people from the embassy
came and they supported me every day
it's they fought for me every day just
because I was a Russian national I'm
very proud of that and you know then you
block in York TVs them Kokua days here
are three Edna more than what you're
considering the complex environment we
have is it realistic to have a law
similar to the second amendment in
Russia cookery I you know was like one
of the committee of Malta were still
sinners for America me no Gidget I've
stuck on pretty voice it even in the
u.s. many people believe that it causes
or murders and facilitates mass violence
especially considering school shootings
in a typical school or Australia would
unfortunately this happens in Russia as
well let's be clear our organization has
always advocated self-defense weapons to
be legal namely pistols and revolvers
today unfortunately we're only allowed
long barrel firearms which obviously
cannot be carried for self-defense
purposes and traumatic guns which sadly
tend to be featured a lot in crime
reports I believe that those who are
fighting crime on the front line I mean
people first and then the police should
be able to use real firearms in defense
situation self-defense situations I
think that can be done in Russia we are
in no way inferior to those countries
that allow it do you - are you ready to
continue your work absolutely
yep Oh stillness absolutely our
organization is headed by a great person
by the way my organization and my
colleagues support me there were letters
and no one abandoned me I'm very
grateful for that the head of our
organization supported and defended me -
I think I should let him know that I
think he should represent organization
and continue doing so and of course I
will support them however due to what
happened the focus of my words will
certainly shift you won't be working
with the NRA I was expelled from the NRA
an official notification was sent to me
to my lawyers saying that now I have a
criminal record
the NRA Charter requires to discontinue
my membership so I was officially
expelled the NRA dodged that bullet that
I see an array of anika nikita key most
Russians maybe have a stereotype of the
NRA what is the organization really like
what are the members like and who runs
there are all sorts of people there
overall the NRA is a great organization
I mean I'll put it this way it's very
successful in terms of campaigning for
gun rights but there is one thing I want
to say and the fact that I was expelled
speaks to that - it has become overly
politicized while I believe that her
organization campaigning for a gun
rights
for self-defense right you know like me
in Russia it should be balanced in terms
of politics because it is more about
general civil rights whereas to an
r-rated a basically supports political
candidates and that's exactly why they
cannot just focus on gun rights anymore
and it's a pity because when I joined an
array when I went to the United States I
looked up to them I came to see how they
built it and I wanted to see this
American Dream you know I was like a
moth to a flame attracted to all these
great things and unfortunately now I
don't know the answer where it is life
great for people it seems to me America
is not the answer no visa marwilt I made
a good thing that's it the American
dream turned into a nightmare
yes it did